in San Francisco is very relaxed
attitude towards some marijuana
Tom Ammiano and I'm an assemblyman for
the 13th district which is San Francisco
lucky me in the 70s the Bay Area was
very uh as always electric and eclectic
but there was a smell of rebellion in
the air there and some of that smelt a
little bit like an herb or so
occasionally at every rally but you know
there was the anti-war movement and
there was civil rights movement the
percolating gay movement the feminist
movement so we know we were hopping and
you know being young is a good thing
because you can teach in the daytime and
do a little part of partying and disco
whatever in the time I get to stay to
myself but also get involved and I did I
got involved with the gay movement the
bad news is is that in the late 70s and
early 80s we were ground zero for aids
in HIV which I think counts for a lot of
the queer involvement in you know
liberation of marijuana laws and they
know people you know not not only we're
familiar with marijuana recreationally
but especially through the AIDS crisis
saw the value in the palliative you know
my own partner passed away because of
hiv/aids and you know in those days the
treatments were brutal and everybody was
freaked out and we really didn't know
what to do but we thought getting
cohesive would be a good plan and it's
true people put aside their differences
in that didn't make a difference in
treatment and who got it but there was
still no no remedy and you know some of
the treatments for cancer and and those
resulted in nausea and certainly that
that helped him and you know I was not
going to be deterred in anything I could
do for him I've you know and so I think
that helps set an attitude and then I
got elected and one of the things that
was brought to my attention of course
was the inequity nationally around
marijuana and you know the political
pulse in San Francisco was a little
different so we started to pass laws and
particularly around 2 15 which is why we
we have dispensaries and the
disruption is minimal because we do have
regulations and unfortunately that
leaves you vulnerable to some of the
more generalized attacks on marijuana if
you know if you don't have a plan and so
you know la doesn't have a plan
currently as we're talking in San Diego
and then the rabidly anti-marijuana
forces use that as an excuse you know
for the nuclear option one of the things
we did was right towards the end is that
pass a resolution that would lower the
priority for the cops and no matter what
the face of law enforcement is at
hearings and things when they're all
black and white and and and moralistic
and etc when you talk to cops offline or
wolf camera or you know they get it they
don't want to waste their time I think
the war on drugs has failed miserably
I'm took this road to when after Harvey
was assassinated in the mayor that you
know maybe activism and being elected
could be blended and ran for the school
board and was a good time to be on the
school board in terms of addressing
issues particularly around HIV AIDS yet
again because there was no curriculum
etc not and I coming from the queer
community you know kid could at least be
proprietary about that and get allies
plus I was a teacher so I knew about
educational issues and you know that
that resonated with people and you know
being openly gay was was a triumph
particularly write a board of education
so and you know San Francisco allows you
know I was saying service goes
opportunity opportunity and I I'm very
very grateful for it and so the next
step was the board of soups the City
Council and then I considered running
for State Office and so that's how
Arnold Schwarzenegger and I will always
be connected forever and ever and ever
so go figure he's an interesting guy you
know I don't think he's allowed to be
himself too much some of his aides you
know really I think give him bad advice
but also you know he's supposed to be
the guy so come on he did actually make
a statement that was somewhat measured
but at the same time supportive of the
league
of marijuana and that was well let's
have a discussion about it I'm sure that
his handlers didn't like that day
because people took that and ran with it
you know Arnold wants legalization
Arnold and smoking in this tent what
what happened there was a mistake in
motivation on the part of Willie Brown
and others they just trivialized
everything he's ever done against this
in San Francisco values and stupidly you
know and with a lot of entitlement
invited him to basically a party it was
the Democratic Party's big annual
fundraiser it wasn't a panel discussion
it wasn't in the chambers you know it
wasn't a teleconferencing call he
basically crashed a party where he was
not welcome and so people reacted in the
great San Francisco way get the hell out
of here boo etc and so forth and and I
was rumored to have said kiss my gay ass
which I have been known to say so all
that made a big splash and you know he
is the gays like the Pope unfortunately
the governor they can veto you can work
your ass off and get Republican support
for things and this not nothing burger
bill came before his desk so I guess
some of his aides had a lot of time on
their hands which I think we should look
into and so the veto message was was
really silly it had no substance but
encrypted in the in the veto message was
I [ __ ] you
the bill currently is looking good I
have a Republican co-sponsor who has a
very libertarian vent so kudos and to
you and judge gray you know who probably
your audience knows he's been terrific
you know the national conversation
around this has been sustained and
excited a lot of interests medical
marijuana is always entwined until you
know we have eric holder you know the
Attorney General issuing the edict that
you cannot and of course rate
dispensaries and then of course the DEA
you know pretty macho guys and girls
they're going to they defied it and they
did raid something recently but you know
that's how it is it's all going to it is
all going to work out and it's it's
they've had a very I think responsible
methodology to putting this on the
ballot they had focus groups etc they
know where they're vulnerable they know
where they're not I think they like me
understand that this could be the time
and you know absolutely let's go for it
let's have that perfect storm so I view
my legislation as which is now pending
as a compliment to the initiative and
vice versa is the initiative perfect no
there are certain things i would like to
tweak but you know not enough to say oh
well I'm going to blow it off it it this
is not the time for that I think
everything on the table everything
positive the initiative if passed and
again it looks good would require
legislation and that's good you know
when to 15 past it was so populists and
then the my peers in the in the
legislature I wasn't there yet you know
gave it the cold shoulder you know there
was a big wedge issue and and that
resulted in a lot of lawsuits and
interpretations and gray areas and you
know to 15 to its credit sustained I
love that you know is it's the right
thing to do we're not going to go away
and you know there are other states now
of course of medical marijuana my
strategy with the legislature is look
here's your initiative it's on the
ballot look it's polling it's going to
win do you want control or not and you
know there is an economic issue here for
everybody this is a capitalist country
for better for worse I don't mind
capitalism as long as we get too greedy
and you know we will see and have an
advantage to the state budget to which
is not the only reason but it is part of
the equation and it does make it a bit
more seductive in the polling in many
areas that are considered conservative
is good so it is a new day it may be a
window and that window might close you
know around all social justice issues
sometimes that happens you know but
things look very very very good and
obviously if it doesn't reach success
say by November or this year then we
just build on that and reintroduce every
and go for it again and
I think we'll see something very
beneficial happen
you